I can't stop listening to the Protomen
I've known about this band and their
Megaman inspired tunes for years now but
after experiencing light up the night
through the immediacy of rock band I
suddenly understand how awesome they
truly are that in essence is the power
of rock band it harnesses the intrinsic
joy of music and presents it in a way
that not only can we play but share as
well
it's a rare accomplishment one that
propels the franchise to great heights
in the late 2000s and that beats again
in the chest of rock band 4
while this fourth installment ditches
rockband threes button having pro guitar
and superfluous keyboard controller the
core gameplay remains largely unchanged
you can grab a classic 5 button guitar
controller plastic drum kit or USB
microphone to play along with a variety
of licensed tracks matching scrolling
color-coded notes in time with the music
so yes it's exactly the gameplay you
already know and love great as that
gameplay may be though rock band 4 does
little to distinguish itself from
earlier games outside of a handful of
hit-or-miss ideas in some cases it even
takes a small step backwards take for
example the game's loosely story driven
campaign mode remember those loading
screens from rock band 2 that showed
your band casually hanging around a
practice space or riding the subway with
all their instruments simple as they
were those scenes told a story this game
nothing but menu text which you know
kind of ruins any feeling of immersion
or investment the game also forces you
to use pre created stand-in characters
any time your friends aren't present to
play as your custom characters which
means it's actually impossible to
maintain a consistent lineup which is a
pretty frustrating betrayal of the rock
and roll fantasy the campaign is trying
to fulfill outside of the campaign rock
band 4 offers a new slightly richer
quick play mode appropriately named play
a show when the track ends play a show
presents players with a selection of
songs and lets band members vote on what
to play next it's novel idea but kind of
pointless when you're standing in the
same room as the rest of your band rock
band 4 is one truly original and truly
exceptional idea is freestyle solos with
this option selected solo sections trade
notes for subtler visual cues there are
basically suggestions for how to use the
solo techniques regardless of whether
you follow along or just totally do your
own thing though the game will produce a
unique new solo that matches your inputs
mashing buttons at random creates a
disruptive cacophony but if you
implement its deeper techniques in a
thoughtful way you can actually create
some really cool sounding stuff like
surprisingly cool it's not the same
adrenaline-fueled fist-bumping thrill of
nailing every note in a really technical
section but there is an unexpected sense
of discovery and reward
similarly drummers now have dynamic
fills which pulled a random pre authored
fill from a library providing a welcome
compromise between the chaos of classic
fills and the predictability of static
fills of course all of this is nothing
without the right soundtrack and sadly
rock band 4 contains the weakest
selection of songs of any rock band game
to date that doesn't mean the whole
games The Lost Cause though there are
some seriously inspired choices here
Protomen being a prime example I was
consistently pleasantly surprised by the
tracks I didn't note beforehand and when
it comes to the classics I have just one
word for you
Panama
plus you'll be able to redownload any
dlc you already own at least in theory
and you can always buy new tracks it's
disappointing rock band 4 song offerings
aren't stronger but at least the rock
band platform remains as strong as ever
rock band 4 recaptures the unadulterated
joy that made the series such a hit but
mainly because it's a relatively
unchanged repackage rock band to a lack
of content and general stagnation hold
this particular edition of rock band
back but new ideas like the freestyle
solos genuinely enhanced the core
experience which remains a sincere and
joyful celebration of music
Oh
you